je regarde encore un écran encore un
rambo
[Musique]
je confirme je les dis et redis je suis
à la tête une école de sciences
politiques et management et je peux
mener à bien ce projet ce qui ne veut
pas dire que je ne ferais jamais de
politique ça je pars en mesure de vous
le dire aujourd'hui mais alors on part
en tout cas je n'en est pas loin
[Musique]
oui non ça ne fait pas trop de problèmes
du coup puisque précisément de cette
école a été créé en réponse au
militantisme et au sectarisme qui
sévissent est malheureusement trop long
trop souvent dans les écoles supérieures
ou dans les universités qui s'incarne
notamment c'est vrai parce qu'on appelle
communément l'islamo gauchisme en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que dans notre
école on est attachés au pluralisme donc
dans les cours et bien il ya toute forme
d'auteur de courant qui sont étudiées
sans discrimination et ensuite aux
étudiants de s'emparer de tout cela et
d'en faire ce qu'ils ont envie d'en
faire
[Musique]
c'est une pratique privée moi je fais
pas la police de la braguette donc
chacun fait ce qu'il veut dans son lit
mais je trouve que ça devient un
problème quand
l'homosexualité comme l'hétérosexualité
d'ailleurs devient une identité une
revendication politique
[Musique]
désespérant c'était à moi j'avoue que
j'ai pas eu le courage de le regarder en
entier donc je vais pas pouvoir vous
faire un jugement extrêmement précis
mais j'en ai regardé comme une partie
importante et notamment le fameux
épisode dénudées bon c'est vrai que
c'est pas tout à fait l'idée qu'on se
fait du charme de l'élégance de
l'esthétique du cinéma français bon et
en plus parce le chapeau s'était même
pas très drôle donc c'est vrai que non
c'était cet été a tristement
renseignement français
oui en acteur
indéniablement yeux c'est un acteur
talentueux c'est un militant
caricatural moins qu'on puisse dire
[Musique]
et bien bonne chance bonne chance je
suis avec toi ma chérie
[Musique]